we got a new kid
bailey over on the mound deceptive
release point meaning
he's 6-9 and 260 pounds he steps halfway
to the plate to deliver the ball so a
little bit different release point
first pitch sky to right field going
back
is garlic and on the edge of the track
makes you catch one away
so one pitch and one out now jake lamb
two and one to jake lamb
oh and jake drives this ball deep right
field it
is gone good start one nothing
jake lamb makes it one-nothing socks in
the first inning
in ball four and here comes your mean
mercedes
a lot of talk about mercedes here
tonight
mercedes right side and through on a
one-two pitch
he gets hits in all counts and two are
on here's adam
eaton who had the night off last night
the 3-2 pitch he got him strike three in
a high fast ball
and there's the first big league
strikeout for bayley over
and broadband threw the ball back to
over
and now bayley will flip that ball to
the dugout there's a keepsake
and it's up to yasmani grand doll now
and the 2-1 pitch a high fly ball
right center field deep garlic going
back on the grass will have a play
in right field pulls it down and that's
out number three
lance lynn going to the mount for his
seventh start he's been brilliant 4-1
era of 130 44
and a 2-2 is swung on and hit on the
ground to the second baseman
madrigal easy play to throw him out
here comes josh donaldson who hit a long
two-run homer one for three
in the game last night and we'll see how
hard he can run here
bare-handed safe at first and donaldson
running hard enough to beat monkata's
throw
to vaughan once we get an infield hit
here from donaldson
and so the twins have the tight run now
at second with sono coming to the play
big miguel
cino hits a pop fly out into short
center field
anderson is calling off everybody and
the short stop makes the catch
the twins leave two white sox won twins
nothing
after one vaughn is on to begin the
second and here is laori garcia
off center field chased by larnick and
he'll get there for the catch going away
showing some range in the outfield
making a nice running catch for the
first out
so two down and now anderson one hop
smashed to short played by simmons he'll
feed
second base to arise and they force out
balls
over comes back with a scoreless second
two down for andrewton
simmons minnesota has yet to hit a ball
out of the infield
popped into center field coming in
and tracking is garcia he gloves it
and the twins are finished in inning two
off to the third so lamb is out for the
second time in three innings
and here is moncado 3-2
ripped to right center and with lamb on
the move we'll see where he ends up
garlic had to go fish it out of the
alleyway monkatta's got an
rbi double and so with lamb
going from first the sox take a
two-nothing lead
they say timing is everything and that
situation on three and two
tony larussa ahead of the 100 right
still
no doubts the batteries mercedes are
singled in the first
and over got him to reach all the way
across the plate
for strike three look at him he's he was
leaning for
looking for something inside protecting
his inside
and that'll get you that chase on a good
breaking ball outside okada at
second two out grundahl hit a fly ball
to right his first time up
rondell drops the bat on that breaking
ball and sends
it up and out of here two-run home run
for he osmani grandel and it's
four-nothing socks the type of guy that
yasmani can take out if he could just
elevate and elevate he did for his fifth
home run
lin back to work on the mound in the
last of the third with a four-nothing
lead
donaldson on the fielder's choice two
outs here's polanco
and through the legs of vaughan and
polanco will reach funko will take over
at first base donaldson the second and
now kepler coming up
we'll see if the twins can make the
white sox pay for the error on a very
routine play
high in the air out into shadow left
anderson will break away as lamb behind
him
had to leave his feet to make the catch
all's well that ends well in the end yep
twins leave
two we go to the fourth top of the order
here's tim anderson well garcia big lead
off of second base
bounce to third donaldson down on the
ground comes
up firing two down nice play for the
second half
very nice play by josh donaldson got a
pretty good break on the ball and
he'll watch him he'll go down make sure
that he gets his glove all the way down
he'll go down to his knee
lancelin on the mound he's only given up
two hits miguel ceno leading off the
twins fourth
deep down the left field line
[Applause]
with a home run his fourth of the year
the twins are on the board he pulled his
hands in
and was able to get the barrel out he
just muscled that ball out he
he didn't really crush it the ball
looked like to me like it
got in on him just a little bit just the
third home run allowed by lance lynn it
gets the twins on the board
trevor larnick oh for one
strike three good sinker first strikeout
for lance lynn
comes up this one just dips out of sight
he got a young hitter well out in front
and wipes him out bottom five coming up
lance land pitching with a three-run
lead
the order here's a rise to bat 3-1 is
hit in the air out into deep center
going straight back on it is leori and
he makes a catch
nice late adjustment as he peeled off
toward the right
and running toward the track he made the
grab
that's his best defensive play of the
year bottom
six still four one socks two down base
is empty
pulled one down the line for a home run
leading off the fourth inning
hit the center field and hit well
hamilton back
on the track going snow with a two-homer
night
and twins creeping a little bit closer
four to two chicago one to left and a
graded bat capped off
with a long one to center well this is
best play of the year as far as i'm
concerned
at the end of six sox four twins two
and tyler duffy taking the mound
for the twins one down and now mercedes
oh see now he threw at mercedes
look that's from last night
duffy threw at your main mercedes the
umpires are gonna come in and talk it
over we had a feeling this might happen
and duffy's been thrown out of the game
oh my goodness
tyler duffy's been thrown out of this
game
and here comes rocco baldelli how to
argue and he's going to be out here
pretty soon too
rocco was hot and it did not even hit
him it did not hit mercedes it was
behind his knees mercedes homered on 3-0
last night the twins took exception
ostadio
jawed at him and there goes rocco
baldella
and right felicia yeah i mean you figure
that eventually he's going to get the
boot normally when you throw out the
pitcher you throw out the manager with
him but
it took a little bit longer this is a
delayed boot and cola may will have as
much time as he needs to get
ready to finish off the mercedes at bat
see this kid has the green light now 3-0
and the pitch no
he takes outside at 93 ball one
and white sox have two on with two out
the first baseman andrew vaughan over
three
runners goal the payoff he got him
strike three swinging at 94.
so duffy ejected rocco ejected colemay
comes in
walks two strikes out two white sox do
not add on
one on one out bottom eight and here is
miguel cino who has
never had a three homer game in his
career
driven to right center field headed
towards the scoreboard
it's gone a three home run game for
miguel ceneaux
one to left one to center
none bigger than that game tying
opposite field
two run shot to right center and cenote
with a three homer night
4-4 bottom nine and now liam hendricks
so it's out number two and now polanco
bats
but the winning run is at third a drive
to the right field corner
and down for a hit polanco walks off the
white sox
twins win the minnesota twins win it 5-4
a fantastic come from behind win
by the minnesota twins at target field
tonight
a line drive rocket to the right field
corner from hori polanco his first
career walk-off hits